Obama a man a hope. February 1968 I joined
the demonstration against the bombing of them.
Big church. Marting Luther King spoke to us
about justice is like mighty stream. After
his lecture I was completely taken in by this
mighty prophetic man. And I lost a book. A
book of poems. I'm a child survivor. And poems
for me were very important because they were
poems about peace, about justice. And I looked
for that book. So I opened my work space at
home and there were all different kinds of
paper, so I looked for the book. Went on my
knees, suddenly a door opens and Martin Luther
King comes in. And he says to me, have you
lost something? I said yes, a book of poems.
He said let's look for it, he goes on his
knees next to me and he looks threw the papers.
I want to say a thousand things as I speak
in silence with him. After a long search he
says, unfortunately my brother, we don't seem
to find it. We shake hands. I think him for
helping me search for it, and he disappears
out of my life, two months later out of the
life of the world. Now in the first week of
President Obama I have a feeling that we together
will find the book of peace.